the city has a lot to lose here are a
few figures in exports financial
services worth more than 25 billion
euros to the EU every year more than 40%
of worldwide euro foreign exchange trade
is handled here more than in all
eurozone countries combined and tens of
thousands of these workers here came
from Berlin Bilbao Budapest without a
visa so what do the bankers and
financiers here think about bricks
bricks here I got nothing to do bricks
no I'm good time sorry thank you no I'd
love to but I've got to meet my wife off
the train
the word brexit alone seems enough to
cause alarm of everyone in the city
the first problem with brexit seems to
be nobody wants to talk about it I've
approached around a dozen law firms
investment companies and bangs like
Deutsche Bank here behind me to discuss
brexit with me and they all said we do
not want to comment but thankfully not
everyone was so reluctant Rob Moffat has
assets of 2.2 billion US dollars under
management his firm is among the top
three venture capital firms in Europe
Moffat invests in young and dynamic
startup companies across the continent
brexit is nothing short of a direct
threat to his business model well I
worry about is the long term impact so
for us success is about building
billion-dollar global success stories
out of Europe then my sequel up in
Helsinki uke's group in Milan Betfair in
London they've been built from every
corner of Europe they've been built with
a very talented team from across Europe
bringing you in the best great developer
and the best French market here and the
best German engineer and I worry that
brexit will reduce the movement greg's
it is a dangerous gamble for the city
the capital that is at risk is not only
financial it is human 11 percent of city
workers come from other EU countries
there is one species of predator in the
city who knows better than all the
others what is at risk here the
headhunters George Hudson is a recruiter
his raw material is people he sniffs out
high profile talent for banks insurances
and law firms his hunting grounds he
thinks are in danger a lot of the people
that I work with have come from the EU
so they're my last three placements have
come from in France Germany Ireland and
that would have been something I'd be
able to do obviously if we didn't have
that free movement and there is another
danger thousands and thousands of jobs
could just vanish and reappear in Paris
and Frankfurt or Dublin we've got six
insurance companies already considering
relocating their headquarters on the
back of just the possibility of there
being a breakfast so yeah I think it'd
be a good idea for the public to
consider you know what people are saying
in the city one of the fastest-growing
and youngest sectors of the city is the
FinTech
industry young entrepreneurs who use
technology and the Internet to build the
money machines for the future London is
the ecosystem they need to thrive full
of young wizards from all over the world
and close to big capital
Hiroki Takeuchi co-founded VOC heartless
five years ago now his company handles
1.9 billion euros of secure online
payments from small companies across
Europe per year
it worries me a lot I think that this
whole discussion is crazy if you look at
how the ecosystems evolved over even
just the last five years since we
started going heartless
it's almost unrecognizable the size
scale ambition number of companies that
are being created all the time
it's really really amazing and my
biggest worry there is that we'll put a
break and a halt to that to that growth
and development of ecosystem for the
young FinTech sector a brexit would mean
that further growth will happen anywhere
in Europe but not this is something
which is really going to impact the
future generation of startups right like
the startups that haven't started yet
and they're going to be formed in the
next year or two years or five years and
when they're thinking okay should I be
set up in London or should I set up in
Berlin you know which way do you think
they're gonna go when the European
market is that much bigger a brexit
looms large across all sectors of
Europe's biggest financial center and
the majorities he are clear but the
mighty City is powerless now stay in or
walk away like all of us the city has to
wait until the countdown to brakes it
stops